non-minimalists
how would we train for that moment that
defines our entire
existence right and that's death
practices so in the past
all of these these initiatory
experiences have been super secretive
closely guarded and wrapped in mythology
right
but you know with neuroscience and with
optimal psychology we actually know
exactly what's going on to the hood
and that's actually kind of one of the
things i'm most excited about to
have laid out in this book which is we
actually have the exact
protocol for a death rebirth experience
and it's open source and it's not
wrapped in mythology
so you can say here you go this is paint
by numbers
rocket ship to your own initiation
wow and once you've had that experience
you can be you can be atheistic you can
say i i simply believe this is just
access to lots of information
and insight awesome you could be
theistic and you could be communic
communing with the
deities and angels of your pantheon it
could be aesthetic
and you're like hey man this is just
gorgeous fractal symmetry as far as the
eye can see
right it doesn't like that's all okay
like there's room for it all
yes on team human right you can skin it
you can sort of you can skin it however
you want so like
believe what you want to believe just
never lose the faith
and right and the faith is semantic in
body like in my bones in my skin i know
this to be true because i've actually
lived it that i that you know to your
point the the
the confucius quote right that i now
realize i'm a dead man walking i now
realize that
i'm not i'm no longer seeking to escape
this to bypass this to sh
to duck my yoke my you know the thing
that's mine to shoulder
and then i come back you know and we
know all these stories right this is
dorothy in the wizard of oz this is
jimmy stewart in a wonderful life this
is ebenezer scrooge on christmas morning
the whole you know and all of the joseph
campbell's hero's journeys
right all have that the hero disappears
he is written off as dead he is in the
belly of the whale
right so so we are in the in the moment
of coming back and
oh nisa godda the indian philosopher
like the other world
is this world rightly seen yes so i've
had this experience
i now come back and i'm like oh my god i
get to live out the rest
you know two decades three decades five
decades however much time i have left
i get to live it as a twice born human
yeah and once we've been born twice
right then dying a second time isn't
nearly so hard
did you enjoy this video if so you can
listen to full episodes of the
minimalists private podcast
available exclusively on patreon visit
patreon.com
the minimalists today